i'm not a democrat you can call me a son
of a [ __ ] and a dishonest opportunist
i'm not you you said you said you are
glad you voted for biden and you said
you're happy you did yeah so you've had
a year and a half to assess that and i
don't and you're still happy about i
don't regret that vote okay so what do
you think what the situation today pat
the situation we're in today why are we
in the situation we are today no no no
stop my friend exactly just no let's get
him off listen no
listen why are we in the situation we
are today tell me
i asked you a specific question which is
what am i a democrat
based on what you're saying that you
don't regret your vote of course you're
a democrat that makes me a democrat even
though i'm not a democrat
you supported policies of a democrat pat
if i vote for a democrat or republican
republicans independence voters if i
claim if i claim i'm not emotional it's
a nice podcast
if i claim i'm not emotional if i claim
i'm not emotional which you're saying
you're not okay if i claim i'm not what
part of your vote today did independents
vote for biden and twenty what part of
your vote
just like because you have an answer my
question how much longer is this guy you
have an ounce you're having a ball you
haven't asked for a question here no you
know i'm sitting five feet from you
that's three feet long three feet and
i'm telling you to your face
i am not a registered democrat what part
of the policies you voted for are you
happy with today
i'm not happy with let me finish a
thought i want to hear it i'm policy as
i've said the specific i'm not happy
with the vast majority of policies biden
has done i'm not a democrat i don't
regret my vote
plenty of independents and republicans
voted for biden too pat they're not
democrats maybe they don't regret their
vote but they're not democrats but
that's the difference though no you
called me a democrat that's indifferent
though you you supported what you're an
american you supported that you're
writing about america you can't say that
it's your opinion because he's calling
no no exactly how stupid adam is it for
me to say that but if you can vouch if
you can validate the point pat sits
there and sometimes but if you validate
the point i'll thank you i love you man
and this isn't a moment if you're
validating the points there's no point
then tell me your policies
what policies you voted for what
policies you voted for pat are you happy
for the vote pat yes i'm not going to
tell you a damn thing
if you continue to call me a democrat
then tell me what no no no no no no you
don't support no no then tell me what
policies you know i'm not then you're
then then i'm a democrat then you
because tell me the policies hey tyler
how much longer tell me the policies
okay joe you can get up and leave i'm
totally fine with it we'll open the door
for you i i i may oh and it's you do joe
this is not emotional yeah it really
isn't
so so they give me a logical answer i'm
not a no no but stop for a minute yeah
you said it's not emotional i left the
republican party two and a half years
ago yeah
i did not join the democratic party i am
an independent right now
so do not call me a democrat but tell me
what policies you supported that today
are working of biden's policies i'd have
a hard time picking
i can give you one sure i'm glad biden
got us out of afghanistan i'm glad i'll
give you two i like this simple
infrastructure bill that of the
bipartisan infrastructure bill that
biden signed into law those are two that
i approve the vast majority of things
biden did i don't so you so you support
the way we left afghanistan absolutely i
support us getting out of afghanistan
let's well let's clarify that do you
support us getting out or you support
the way we left i'll answer that i
supported us getting out because that
started under trump and the doha
agreement hey hey my friend
yeah that was a promise of trump's that
i supported and i'm glad biden got it
done and i believe that any how we any
way we would have gotten out of
afghanistan was going to be ugly and
messy and it was but i respect biden for
having the balls for doing it so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]